hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom and if you're anything like me
you believe that a glass of wine at
eight pm makes you a better mom it's a
pour yourself a glass and let's talk
about stuff tonight we're drinking some
really fancy rose a because why not
wine here's why I'm drinking tonight my
youngest son just started daycare and
it's about a 45-minute drive so he
doesn't like anything about this new
situation he screams the entire way to
daycare and the entire way back so I'm
sitting in about an hour and a half's
worth of screaming every day so Cheers
so tonight's topic are you ready to have
kids so there's obviously the standard
like oh are you financially stable are
you emotionally stable probably not
that's not what we're gonna go into
tonight because yeah that's important
but like there are some other unspoken
things that nobody really talks about
that you've gotta know too first
have you ever killed a cactus because
cacti are very hard to kill they only
need to be watered like once a month so
if you have managed to kill one you
probably shouldn't have kids but I have
actually killed several cacti so I don't
know if that's bad next have you ever
fallen asleep while driving and not
gotten into an accident because raising
kids is just as dangerous and you're
expected to do it while constantly
exhausted there is a very special type
of tire that you get to experience once
you've had kids I have done the weirdest
[ __ ] from lack of sleep like I'll go
outside and see that I've given our dog
a bottle I've given her a bottle I like
giving my kid dog food not have not
gonna put my kids dog food maybe they've
eaten it a couple times it's fine
this rose' is kind of strong can widen
be stronger than others next
how strong are the soles of your feet
because you're about to be walking on
Legos every day when my husband and I
first got married he was very adamant
about there are not going to be any kid
toys and you were about their rooms and
I was like yeah okay sure buddy hey okay
hey hey everywhere hey this is my living
room right here this [ __ ]
next you like to spend whole your own
day because once you have kids your day
is going to revolve around naps if your
child skips a nap
they're no longer a child they're
suddenly a little gremlin and the more
time that progresses the more gremlin
they become so my four-year-old is at
this stage where he thinks he doesn't
need naps anymore after the time that
he's missed it it's always like 5:00
p.m. use melts into this like puddle of
screech when my kids skip their maps it
is 6 p.m. mandatory bedtime like no
questions you get in bed and count some
sheep even if you don't know how to
count neither of my kids know it's not a
count but figure it out hold on hold on
next you're going to the bathroom and
your sunglasses accidentally fall in the
toilet do you pick them up because if
you do you're probably ready for kids
like this morning my one and a half year
old woke up I like pick him up and I
feel something kind of wet so I lay him
down and I pull my arm up and my arm is
just like brown it's [ __ ] it has leaked
at the back of his diaper all onto his
back and so when I picked him up I just
like squish it all over my arm
I don't even blink I just take some
wipes wipe it off get some sanitizer rub
it on wash it off with soap no harm no
foul just got [ __ ] all over my arm who
cares I'm really enjoying this enamel
glass because it doesn't show how much
is like being drink you don't know if my
glass is full you don't know if it's
empty I could
only had like two sips this whole time
so how did you do hope you were keeping
score if you weren't keeping score why
the [ __ ] are you watching this shouldn't
say the f-word
so how did you do because if you scored
two out of three two out of ten what how
many things I can say it doesn't even
matter what your score is because to be
honest you could be already on paper
nothing is gonna prepare you for
actually having kids I read probably
seven parenting books
yeah it's great you need to cut your
kids grapes in half that doesn't teach
you how to deal with a certain child's
temper tantrum one of my son's like
sweep have it on the back the other one
likes to be held and rocked very very
close there's no book on parenting
that's gonna teach you how to parent
your child so [ __ ] books don't read so
that's it for now I'm Hannah your
friendly neighborhood wine mom and if
there's anything you want me to talk
about even in the comments because I
read them and I'd love to talk about
what you guys are interested in and to
all you people about the comments saying
oh this is why I never want kids you
will have kids I was one of those people
and now I have to stir until next time
go make some babies goodnight
Oh
gave you a firm that's what I gave you